okay hey everyone it's Mike vatos
welcome to the owner closed market
analysis for Tuesday October 3rd 2017
and another day another new high the Dow
is up 0.4% to a new record at 22 641 the
euro is being a stabilised following and
Catalonia's independence vote and the
violence over the weekend and sort of
put an end to this week's dollar surge
an economic data front in the US vehicle
sales came in at 18 point 6 million
annualized in September which is the
strongest in 12 years well I believe
that was mostly driven by replacement
demand in in Houston were you know
there's a lot of where there was all
that flooding so it's going to I think
it's gonna give a major lift to consumer
spending at the end of what had been a
lackluster third quarter so you know
with that said let's jump into the
presentation this disclaimer is
something I say every day this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making any
type of investment decision Futures
Trading contains justanswer risk and is
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading in only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results tools I use
in this presentation the order flows
trader the Delta scalper and the price
rejecter so let's take a look like I
said you know a big another new high in
the equities so we'll talk about ESPYs
first let me just get the for range
chart alright so coming into the day you
know I thought I remember looking at
this chart thinking oh my god it's just
dead but you know what because we're
coming in here is 25 29 and a half hi 25
25 25 below so you're talking about four
and a half point range you're coming
into the cash open that's nothing
four-and-a-half points is nothing in the
espys
but when you're looking at it I think
Anala we're set for a boring date but
that's when you got to be on your toes
because it's these coming into the
mornings with these tight ranges that's
when you get some nice breakouts right
it's easy to get lulled into thinking oh
it's gonna be a quiet day but you know
if this market picks up a head of steam
in one direction or the other you know
you get
going so you know 8:35 just after the
cash open you got this Delta Cal Pro
giving you a signal and it followed it
up right back up with a stack sound
imbalance so not the best way to start
your trading day you know you got a nice
you got a signal sort of in the middle
of the day's range you know which is
small already and then you just get an
opposite signal right after that so just
you know sort of walk it forward sort of
going nowhere nowhere nowhere and
instead you're seeing a lot of
imbalances and I mean look at this they
got stacked imbalance sitting here you
got three thousand you got six hundred
and got thirteen hundred eleven hundred
one thousand and you're seeing these
deltas eighteen hundred two thousand
four hundred three thousand six hundred
what's your impression what's your
thinking you thinking it's probably
gonna sell off you know I'm never
looking at this thinking well you know
there's there's quite a bit of selling
but at the same time I expect that
market to move lower into some new lows
with that type of selling then you come
down here you get within you know two
ticks of the low you get down to 26 all
those five and a half and it stops and
it reverses it starts going back I'll
say going back up but you know you got
the the up candle kind of a small Delta
you know at one point you had a negative
Delta of 20 to 80 but it finished up at
plus 392 then the next bar you got you
know bullish ratio you got that single
print got a nice strong Delta 1100 but
you're right back in the middle of your
value area so you know are you excited
no not really
you know nothing special going on at
this point again you know you're
training in the middle of your value
area it's hard to get excited about any
move at this point you know you what you
wanted something concrete
so you rally you rally you up to within
a tick of your high up here at twenty
nine and at twenty nine and a quarter
okay but then what happens is it you hit
the upper end of your of your range and
the bar turns and starts coming back
down into the range again you know
another red candle here you have point
of controls lined up one two you know is
this going to be your resistance you
start trading lower you trade back down
to unchanged at twenty seven and a
quarter and then still a negative Delta
right eight six seven here two five two
six two
five six zero rather you know on this
little move up you're thinking hey you
know maybe maybe we could break out
right we got some nice rising deltas
here well then it hits here it's kind of
a weak Delta the negative negative okay
and you're back down into your value
area and then again here okay start
coming down negative Delta income okay
maybe you know maybe we're rejecting
these high prices up here at twenty nine
twenty nine and a half and because you
see it selling coming in you don't
really see very aggressive selling right
you just CEO on a balance here one
imbalance there and then what happens
you get right down to the 26 area again
and your bounce you know you turn back
up you got the green candle the up
candle it got positive Delta is negative
early but finished positive going
sideways here you got a red candle then
you got a green candle again you were
trading back down at 26 now
notice what's happening here for 22 the
first time you hit this second time 272
third time 111 okay I think that's me
that that's a very indicative sign that
prices down here are being rejected
below 25 26 you know there's not a lot
of selling interest below that and then
what do you get here you get the Delta
scalper giving you a buy okay mmm
you know is that is that a goal I don't
know it's it's right in the middle of
your value area you know it's right at
unchanged and what happens is you trade
back down instead of kitten 26 you hit
26 in a quarter and then you get the red
candle here we got some nice volume
going through here right around
unchanged at seven and a quarter you
know nine thousand eight thousand okay
that Delta minus three thousand four
hundred at this point I'm thinking you
know it's yeah even I got this Delta
scalper giving me a buy right you know
this is the kind of a difficult decision
to be making here I said I do like that
you got the declining volume when you
keep hitting 26 then you didn't hit 26
this time I like that you got the Delta
scalper but you know some stuff swinging
on my mind here you got these imbalances
here a big one here three thousand a
huge one here nine five 1173 so I got a
strong negative Delta 3,000 is quite
strong for a four range chart I'm
thinking hey you know what know maybe
this market is going to sell off but
again it
right in the middle of evaluation so I'm
not surprised to see you know big volume
there and then we break down we get down
below 26 I'm thinking oh right we
broke down below 26 but look at this
support of volume here 1700 at 26
1400 there even goes offered at 5 and
3/4 but doesn't actually trade five and
a half okay so this bar is actually a
bullish bar right I mean the fact that
we couldn't go lower
and take out that low is telling me you
know what maybe there is some support of
buying in this market next bar Delta
scalper kicks in and right around the
same level as the previous one you see
some nice you know imbalance in this bar
here 25 24 54 16 22 nice strong Deltona
2900 again you know it's coming on the
back of these bars with strong negative
Delta but this bar even though it's got
negative Delta's is looks supportive to
me it's telling me there's buyers coming
in here I mean this is the beauty of
using a footprint chart as you can see
these volumes and make that decision
yourself saying hey you know what
yet 1735 traded here 1455 traded here
even when offered nothing traded their
buyers came in scooped that up scoop
this up and start trading it higher here
you know that's how you analyze the
order flow then BOOM what happens the
next bar up point controls all higher
from this first one where do you train
down trade you trade down to this point
of control so if you're taking this as
your swing low the opponent controls are
going to be your support on this move
and you got the Delta scalper as well
and what happens boom you start trading
up to the highs 50 25 29 and a half
think out the high take out the high
stake out the highs so you move up from
you know the 28 area all the way up to
32 up here you know it was a slow move
was a slow grind granted you know you're
talking eleven o'clock right here up to
this high at just about three o'clock
2:45 but you know there's no reason to
be getting short and on any point of
this move up you know if you had to
position yourself you'd have to position
yourself long but it's just unfortunate
it's taken forever for this move but you
put it in strong volumes on this move up
I mean look at these footprints here
you know you got ten thousands trading
you know here here
seven thousand fifteen thousand ten
thousand fourteen thousand and you're
going up up up eventually you make some
new highs closing up on the highs of the
day so you know even though the move
will look nice it was just a slow slow
grind up there you know I prefer to be
quicker but you know you said early in
the day you had that tight range
I said don't don't think oh it's a tight
range I'll turn off my computer and you
know do something else I mean you can
but yeah you also often get explosive
moves off of tight ranges right the
whole rebo right range extension
breakouts all the time the mark work all
the Toby cradle work you know where do
you get the range extension breakouts
they come after tight ranges narrow
ranges right you do research search up
look up Google and Toby cradles work you
know type in and r7 and see what all
that's about narrow range and you know
that's that's where you get the moves
from so it's it's boring as heck to be
sitting through a four point range but
you know it's out of those tight ranges
that the the big moves often come okay
so next up I'll talk about crude crude
oil there's a nice interesting things in
the order flow today so yeah 208
you had your low here little of the day
some decent volume down here you know FX
trader so you got a pin bar you know
it's automatic by okay fair enough
but anyway we rallied up to the highs
you get up to this high and you know and
I love these types of highs right
because a great areas too short what do
I mean by these types of highs is you
sort of going up on you know we can in
volume yeah I mean we can in Delta yes
you have a strong Delta five five four
here but then you hit your high on 18
then you got the negative Delta in the
bar afterwards then it just sort of
mixes up here positive 164 negative 126
again a strong negative 561 you know the
sign was up in here with the deltas
copper giving you the sell but again
even if you're getting short off of this
bar here I still think it's a good area
to be looking to get short you trade
some decent volume around here around 50
53 but you
still hanging around off this high and I
mean I'll say off this high I mean at
this point you talking about a range of
68 to 34 so a 34 point range so again
right around the middle of your your
your range but still I think it's a good
opportunity even if you didn't see this
Delta scalper signal up here and you're
just analyzing the Delta the fact that
you hit your high on a small Delta
negative Delta after it all overall
basically the rest of the bars mean you
got one positive here these two so
unless a cancel each other out but one
64 and it came right back with a
negative 126 there than minus 500 again
is a great shorting opportunity and just
sort of goes sideways sideways before it
makes the move down down down down into
new lows here you know down to 24
eventually hit this low at 22 just
before 8 o'clock
you got a divergence no ratio no ratio
in the next bar and you just sort of
hang around you start to rally okay you
know again I'm not gonna say there's
really much signs in here and the order
flow to be mine at this point but this
bar here I thought was a great buying
opportunity sorry excuse me
so that this call point control right
towards the bottom you got the negative
Delta and why you have the negative
Delta well you got some very strong
binding here look at this bottom part of
this bar 251 387 702 125 even unfinished
business here you know 32 so is offered
here's bid and offer didn't rate on the
bid side and the buy-in just came right
back and lifted this market up I love
this type of bar and you know it's I
know people say unfinished business you
know mark it's gonna come back to it
yeah I mean eventually it might I don't
know I could draw a line here at 50
whatever that is 50 38 and maybe you
know and in the future we come back and
test it and then I could say that's
unfinished business but that's you know
that's not part of you know how I trade
but you know just is this simple just
watch the order flow look for areas look
for pockets of heavy volume as support
or resistance I mean it's as basic stuff
and you've seen it right there and it's
a very decent buying opportunity where's
your stop going to be it's going to be
around this point in control or even
below the low of this bar it's not gonna
be so far away it's just going to be
very tight so you got a very limited
risk on this trade you know you're
talking not even 10 ticks and what's
your potential you know from going up
from 46 all the way up I mean we rally
up to new highs you know that that's a
those are the type of trades that you
want to get you know where you could
rally up to and make new highs from a
from a Louis area so but anyway you know
again I I know those unfinished business
people will come out and say look let's
just draw this horizontal line here here
yeah yeah and traded there I put with
unfinished business you trade there you
supposed to buy it okay you buy it
what's going on what happens is yeah you
you do go up from it but you spend a lot
of time beneath that that area so if
you're buying it here at 38 now granted
any time you're trying to buy a pullback
you know you don't know where a pullback
is going to stop in this case it got
down to 30 31 you know do you want to
take you know I don't know where you'd
be placing your stop I mean I can't say
you've given 10 ticks okay maybe you
know eventually would have stopped you
out possibly over here over that's 10
ticks you know eventually made new lows
so you know can you use unfinished
business yeah you can but you know is a
target where the market come back to
yeah and I don't think that that's not
how it was originally intended to be
used you know it was tended to be used
where you pull back to that area you hit
it then you rally not you pull back
through it trade around it and then then
make a rally okay so this time let's
take a look at the bond market here so
um you know also I say a tighter range I
think we had a bigger bigger range in
the espys this morning but you know we
made a low here at 5:22 you do have the
one of the bottles indicators giving you
a buy signal right on that low here
previous low you had price rejecter you
also had the divergence but you know
divergence by itself is not necessarily
a good sign this one's a little bit
better sign but anyway
um again it's 5:00 in the morning you
know had you taken this by here you know
it came right back with the bearish bar
immediately afterwards stops you up then
you get another buy opportunity here I
could didn't make a decent little rally
promo for up to around the 12 area then
we hit the new low again let's take a
look at this low and I love this new low
here for a number of reasons one you got
the less volume first time was 2 to 3
second time 33 I like that you also have
a divergence and a ratio I like that so
you know I've got a bunch of stuff I
like going on in here you've actually
got the you know next bar or bullish
ratio of bullish ratio here the only
thing I don't really have going on in
here is a delta scalper signal that
would be nice to get it but you know
it's it's conditions just aren't met but
you know ratio and divergence that's my
go-to trade that's my bread-and-butter
trade you know I talk about those every
day and here it is right at right 754
ratio and divergence you know again from
the O for area where do we trade up to
trade boom all the way up to the highs
of the day make new highs you know you
do have a three in a row right here with
racial racial ratio you get a pullback
but you know the ideal entry is between
the two point controls you don't get it
here so you don't get the ideal entry
off that 3 in a row but you know how
many other methods of trading is going
to give you a trading opportunity from
the low of the day potentially to new
highs of the day you know I mean this
moving average is gonna give it to you
it's trading view AK wanna give it to
you know V weapon you know and your view
app your trading you know you're looking
for reversion to the mean you know but
you know order flow you can find areas
again it's not about trying to pick lows
of the day no it's not about that at all
it's about the market telling you at
this low hey this is a buying
opportunity
ok and it or does it do it rallies from
the low all the way up to the highest
doesn't get any better than that
you hit your high up here what do you
got you got your divergence and you got
your ratio up here on this high you got
less volume the first time was 38 second
times 16 and what happens does it sell
off to back down to the lows no but you
get a little bit of a move down from you
know the 2021 area down into the
call this you know 17 area 16 area
eventually did go a little bit lower but
you know if I see it trading like this I
probably be looking to get out at a few
ticks I'm not going to hold it much
longer than that eventually it does
rally back up to some new highs but
again you know even if you got just one
trade a day you know a ratio and
divergence you know if you got one set
up to look for a ratio and divergence
you see you rally from the low up to the
high you got the sell with the ratio and
divergence up here you know the second
one not as great as the first one but
okay you know if any time you get a few
ticks out of the market is is better
than losing a few ticks out of the
market but this first one is giving you
you know good 20 ticks okay real quick
but just look at five years not much
going on in the order flow in the five
years actually again you know you made
your low here at 5:00 in the morning you
have a volatile indicator giving you a
buy you up here I thought this bar was
kind of bearish but you know it's a bar
right in the middle of your value area
then it comes back with a stack buying
imbalance and I like stack mine and
balances and bullish ratios afterwards
does it rally well yeah it does the
rally is about four ticks then you got
price rejecter running running into a
price rejection up here you got the
bearish ratio as well and you sell off
again you know what I see you know sort
of alternating buy and sell signals to
me that that's a market that's going
sideways more than anything you know
it's one thing if it's just a lot of buy
signals but you know you got sell signal
by signal by signal cell signal cell
signal Delta scupper buy signal you know
it's just not shaping up is there any
way you make the new highs you get up
here you got the divergence no bearish
ratio or anything like that just the
divergence that you just sort of go
sideways but this area in here it's it's
choppy but you know honestly when I look
at you know when I want to watch in the
market and I'm getting you know
conflicting signals that's when you stay
out right you want you want things you
know you want the conditions to be
clearer right I mean it was clearer in
the bonds here at this low all right you
got your les gusta volume you've got you
know the ratio we got the divergence you
know that was a lot clearer than what
you have here in the five years is just
alternate y'all you got this bear
bar you got the stack mind imbalance you
got the bullish ratios and you got
bearish parish ratio you got price
rejecter giving yourself Delta scalper
giving yourself you've run right back
into a bullish single print a bullish
ratio you know it's don't make trading
more complicated than it should be you
know if you're getting a lot of
conflicting signals conflict in conflict
conflicting signals don't take any
trades wait you know wait for things to
be clearer I mean no one's putting no
one's forcing you to take a trade right
I mean it's up to you to to take the
trade or not alright so thanks for
watching this video to learn more about
trading with Oracle's visit my website
order flow is calm and if you're
interested in the Delta scalper go to
Delta scalper calm be sure to subscribe
to the youtube channel as well if you
want to be updated on the latest videos
coming out hit subscribe there and
there's a little bell if you click on
the little bell you'll be notified
whenever I post a new video so thanks
everyone have a great day bye bye